mr speaker we are at a critical moment
a tipping point to quote the deputy
chief medical officer
we have all seen the clear and alarming
trend in infection rates
the virus is now spreading in all areas
of the united kingdom
though much faster in some areas than
others and as the prime minister said
and the deputy chief medical officer
said there are now more patients in
hospital
with covid today than when the country
went into lockdown on the 23rd
of march and deaths are rising nobody
should be under any illusion
about where this is heading or of the
need for device
for decisive action the question today
is whether the restrictions announced by
the prime minister
can bring the country back from the
brink whether they can regain control of
the virus
and provide the support and confidence
that local businesses
and communities need that's how high the
stakes now
are so we will consider the package
we will look at the small print of the
local mayors councillors and leaders
in the areas most affected and will
scrutinize the economic package
that sits alongside them but i have to
say
to the prime minister i'm now deeply
skeptical that the government has
actually got a plan
to get control of this virus to protect
jobs
or regain public trust we've tried to
give the prime minister the benefit of
the doubt
but it increasingly feels like the prime
minister is several steps behind the
curve
and running to catch up with a virus
that he has lost control of
long ago it was less than three weeks
ago
22nd of september that the prime
minister came to this house
to announce new restrictions he said
then that the measures he was
introducing then
would i quote curb the number of daily
infections
that those restrictions were carefully
judged to achieve the maximum reduction
in the r number
that hasn't happened those measures have
not worked
we wouldn't be here today if they had
and there's a pattern here on the 1st of
july
the prime minister told us of his new
whack-a-mole strategy to control local
outbreaks
20 areas have now been in restrictions
for over two months
19 have seen their infection rates rise
some by very large amounts
so those measures have not worked either
in may the prime minister boasted of a
world beating track and trace system
he told us it would be a real game
changer in the fight against the virus
we've debated this many times since
but last week the figures were the worst
yet
the prime minister promised a hundred
percent of test results
would be turned around in 24 hours the
latest figure mr speaker
for in-person testing is just 24
being turned around in that period this
serial failure
combined with the repeated leaks and
briefing to the newspapers in the last
few days
have fatally eroded public confidence
just when we need it most
so can the prime minister tell us what
reassurance can he give us that these
measures today
will be sufficient to get the virus
under control
will he finally accept that trace and
isolate
should be handed over to local
authorities as we've been saying for
months will he accept that the support
packages announced by the chancellor
simply won't work for many thousands of
people particularly those
on the minimum wage mr speaker there's
huge anger about this
in areas under lockdown and there's a
huge gap in the government's plan
and will he confirm that mayors local
leaders council leaders and others will
be fully involved
in any future decisions finally i want
to say this the prime minister i know
that there will be some on his side who
will oppose further restrictions
there will be those that will look at
the data and tell him
to disregard it or say the cost of
acting now is too high
i want to be clear the worst thing the
prime minister can do
is not act quickly and decisively enough
or to keep coming
back to this house every couple of weeks
with a new plan that doesn't work
and isn't up to the scale of the task we
need to break
that cycle finally get on top of the
virus rebuild public confidence
i hope the measures announced today will
do so
but the house and the country will be
deeply skeptical
whether they can